as perhaps the greatest chess player of
all time when you look introspectively
your psychology throughout your career
what was the bigger motivator the love
of winning or the hatred of losing tough
question I have to confess I never heard
it before
each is again congratulations it's quite
an accomplishment losing was always
painful for me it was almost like a
physical pain because I knew that if I
lost the game it's just because I made a
mistake so it I always believed that the
result of the game had to be decided by
the quality of my play okay you may say
it sounds arrogant but it helped me to
move forward because I always knew that
there was room for improvement so it's
the was there the fear the mistake
actually fear of mistake guarantees
mistakes and the difference between top
players and very top is that it's the
ability to make a decision without
predictable consequences you don't know
what's happening it's intuitively I can
go this way or that way and they're
always hesitations people like your
you're just you know at the crossroad
you can go right you can go left you can
go straight you can turn and go back and
the consequences are just very uncertain
yes you have certain ideas what happens
on the right or on the left or on just
you know if you go straight but it's not
enough to make well calculated choice
and when you play chess at the very top
is it's it's it's about your inner
strength so I can make this decision I
will stand firm and I'm not going to
waste my time because I feel confidence
that I will go through going back the
original question is I would say neither
it's just it's the it's love for winning
hateful losing there were important
elements psychological elements but the
key element it's the I would say the the
draw
having forced was always my passion for
for making it make any difference it's
just I can move forward and I can always
it's I can always enjoy not just playing
but creating something new creating
something new how do you think about
that it's just finding new ideas in the
openings you know some regional plan in
the middle game it's actually that
helped me to make the transition from
the game of chess where I wasn't very
top - to another life where I knew I
would not be number one
I would don't be necessarily on the top
but I could still be very active and
productive by my ability to make the
difference by influencing people say
joining the democratic movement in
Russia or talking to people about
human-machine relations there's so many
things were I knew my influence may not
be as decisive as in chess but still
strong enough to help people to make
their choices so you can still create
something new that makes a difference in
the world outside of chess
you